political realities have forced
president biden to back away from his
positions on two important issues the
president is home from a mideast trip
where he fist bumped saudi arabia's de
facto ruler who he had strongly
criticized in the past he's also
acknowledged that efforts to tackle
climate change have hit an unmovable
roadblock in the u.s senate nancy cordes
is at the white house with more so nancy
good morning did this trip
give the president anything he wanted
what was the upside here
we don't know if he got what he wanted
yet vlad and that's because while the
president made this controversial trip
to saudi arabia to meet with the leaders
of some of the biggest world's biggest
oil producing countries
those leaders still have not made firm
commitments about producing more oil in
a way that would bring down oil prices
here in the u.s and around the world now
the president said that he got
assurances behind closed doors that
saudi arabia's crown prince would pump
more oil but white house advisers say
it's going to take a couple weeks to
find out for sure which countries decide
to ramp up production and buy how much
for now though that ambiguity appears to
have rattled the oil markets and it's
pushing oil prices back up again today
vlad all right nancy let's stay on the
subject of energy the president's
climate change agenda took a really big
hit at home last week when west virginia
senator joe manchin as you know
announced he would not support a
reconciliation bill that contained the
administration's climate change
provisions so where does the president
go from here
well he appears to have accepted the
legislative reality that he's not going
to be able to pass his climate change
agenda at least not right now so instead
he's now urging democrats to pass the
elements of the biden agenda that
senator manchin says he will support
like allowing medicare to finally
negotiate some prices for
pharmaceuticals manchin's announcement
at the end of last week infuriated his
fellow democrats and its stymies climate
commitments that president biden made to
world leaders mr biden says that he is
going to try to do some of it by
executive action but that is not nearly
as effective vlad
all right to be continued nancy thank
you very much